all right so the nexus 4 is pretty hard
to get right now and the nexus 7 is just
plain awesome so welcome to the nexus
giveaway
so my last video was about the most
overpriced things in all of tech but you
know it's not overpriced the nexus 4 and
the nexus 7. in fact they happen to be
on the opposite end of that spectrum
where you get the most bang for your
buck but that's a whole separate video
um but anyway this is an opportunity for
you to get these for zero dollars for
absolutely free so it's pretty simple to
get in on this one it's a very
straightforward giveaway but this
giveaway is twofold there's the nexus 4
part and there's the nexus 7 part the
nexus 7 part is here on youtube i'm
partnering up with austin from duncan
33303 and lamar wilson and in order to
enter all you have to do is be a
subscriber of all three channels there
will be annotations and links below and
just leave a comment down below and you
are entered to win now all three of us
have a video so if you enter my video
that's one entry if you enter all three
of ours you get a total of a maximum of
three entries and while you're at it
definitely be sure to check out the rest
of their videos because they make some
awesome content and without them this
giveaway wouldn't be possible so that's
it that's all you have to do to enter to
win the nexus 7. the nexus 4 giveaway is
on facebook it's the social network that
pretty much all of us are on and if
you're not you don't have to enter it
but in order to enter all three of us
have a facebook page if you like all
three of our facebook pages you can
leave a comment each of us has a post a
specific post that you leave a comment
on to enter you probably it'll be
obvious which post it is but the links
again will be down below for that one
comment on each of our posts is an entry
so again you get a maximum of three
entries to win the nexus 4 and that's it
you're entered this is an international
giveaway so no matter where you are on
the planet you can win a nexus 4 or you
can win a nexus 7. the winner will be
picked and it will be picked in a live
show after it's randomly selected of
course and don't worry you don't have to
make it to the live show to win but you
should probably go anyway because it's
going to be quite a bit of fun we'll
also announce the winners on social
media and get in contact with them and
of course if they don't respond in like
a week or so we'll pick the second place
winner but you get the idea uh you're
probably going to want to go to the show
and check it out and you'll be able to
see all the rest of the content these
guys make which is awesome so there you
go you can enter the nexus 4 giveaway
you can enter the nexus 7 giveaway you
can enter both totally up to you uh but
i know the nexus four is kind of hard to
buy right now so it'll be cool to win
one of these for free either way thank
you for watching i'd have some pretty
awesome videos coming up in the near
future and if you want to check out the
full rules and all that stuff just to
make sure you're doing it right the link
is down below the like button all the
information you need is down there where
i'm pointing again i hate pointing there
but it's there thanks for watching stay
tuned best of luck to you if you're
entering and i'll talk to you guys in
the next video
peace
you